voilà ce qui se passe quand on engage un
arnaqueur je peux convaincre n'importe
qui de n'importe quoi c'est une vraie
science est aspiré confiance je veux
connaître avec tes compétences actuelles
pas question tu pourrais peut-être même
prendre d'otages ou c'est trop nul
sérieux tu trouve ça sexy c'est vraiment
ça c'est assez d'accord on y va on a une
trentaine tout le monde a un pourcentage
on ne perd vite et hostile et qui la vie
c'est notre stagiaire de la zone non
farhad je me la saute pas de vrai bon
jeu le rôle jusqu'au bout mais il craque
jamais mais puis souhait
viens pas un seul black à cette fête
bienvenue au club
tu es une criminelle peut-être la plus
douée que je connaisse alors à quand le
coup du siècle je te prenais pour un
gros calibre
saks durable tu parles du coup on se
fera tellement de fric qu'on pourra
prendre notre part soit bien celui-là ça
doit se faire discrètement sont pas vus
je sens que je peux te faire confiance
mais tu me connais pas félicitations m
c'est quelqu'un que tu as pas à terrain
français tous acquiescent je mise 1
millions sont victimes urgent maintenant
ça devient intéressante là il n'y a pas
de place pour les affaires de coeur
ça pourrait être fatal ça fait quoi
il ya deux catégories de personnes les
marteaux et les clous à toi de décider
ce que tu veux être
et ce belge